en este y el siguiente vídeo vamos a
aprender a calcular el costo de
oportunidad ya determinar quién tiene la
ventaja comparativa en la producción de
bienes a partir del uso de datos de una
tabla de producción y de una tabla de
insumos si examinamos nuestra curva de
posibilidades de producción en la
gráfica de la izquierda vemos la
producción potencial de dos bienes
zapatos y balones de básquetbol en dos
países diferentes el país en azul y el
país ve en verde observa que los datos
de esta curva de posibilidades de
producción también están representados
en la tabla de la derecha el país puede
producir hasta seis pares de zapatos por
trabajador o hasta ocho balones de
básquetbol por trabajador en cambio el
país ve puede producir hasta cuatro
pares de zapatos o cuatro balones de
básquetbol por trabajador observa que en
esta tabla los datos mostrados son la
producción ésta es la producción
potencial de los dos bienes que el país
puede producir con una cantidad fija de
insumos los trabajadores son insumos y
cada trabajador puede producir las
cantidades de balones y de zapatos
indicados en la tabla
calcular el costo de oportunidad de los
zapatos y los balones de básquetbol en
estos dos países
podemos utilizar el siguiente método
sabemos que por cada seis pares de
zapatos voy a escribir seis z que el
país produce deja de producir ocho
balones de básquetbol los recursos
necesarios para producir seis pares de
zapatos también podrían producir ocho
balones para hallar el costo de
oportunidad de los zapatos lo único que
tenemos que hacer es dividir ambos lados
de la ecuación entre seis así podemos
ver que el costo de oportunidad de un
par de zapatos es 8 sextos o 4 tercios
de un balón de básquetbol vamos a
convertir estas fracciones en decimales
porque es más sencillo comparar
decimales que comparar fracciones que
podrían tener distintos denominadores
sigamos adelante y transformemos estos
cuatro tercios en decimales esto nos da
un costo de oportunidad de 1.33 balones
de básquetbol por cada par de zapatos
producidos en el país
calculamos ahora el costo de oportunidad
de los balones en términos de zapatos el
país a puede producir ocho balones de
básquetbol o seis pares de zapatos
para hallar el costo de los balones
solamente dividimos ambos lados entre 8
y vamos a obtener un costo de
oportunidad de tres cuartos de par de
zapatos por cada balón de basquetbol
nuevamente vamos a convertir esto a
decimales para que sea más fácil
comparar los costos de oportunidad entre
países
tres cuartos de un par de zapatos nos
dan como resultado 0.75 pares de zapatos
por cada balón ahora tenemos los costos
de oportunidad de zapatos y balones para
el país va a ser mucho más rápido
calcular estos costos de oportunidad
para el país ve porque el país ve puede
producir cuatro pares de zapatos o
cuatro balones de básquetbol lo que le
da un costo de oportunidad de zapatos de
un balón de básquetbol por cada par de
zapatos de igual forma para los balones
con los recursos que se necesitan para
producir cuatro balones de básquetbol el
país podría producir cuatro pares de
zapatos dividimos ambos lados entre
cuatro y obtenemos un costo de balones
de un par de zapatos por cada balón de
básquetbol
ahora tenemos toda la información que
necesitamos para determinar quién tiene
la ventaja comparativa en estos dos
bienes con esta información podremos
de qué manera pueden especializarse y
comerciar entre sí ambos países para
obtener un beneficio mutuo veamos
primero los zapatos observamos que el
país puede producir zapatos a un costo
de oportunidad de 1.33 balones por cada
par de zapatos y el país ve puede
producir zapatos a un costo de
oportunidad de un balón por cada par de
zapatos claramente el país ve puede
producir zapatos al costo de oportunidad
más bajo por lo tanto el país ve debería
especializarse en la producción de
zapatos porque es donde tiene una
ventaja comparativa en cuanto a los
balones el país puede producirlos a un
costo de oportunidad de 0.75 pares de
zapatos por cada balón mientras que el
país bebé debe dejar de producir un par
de zapatos por cada balón esto da al
país a la ventaja comparativa debido a
que tiene un costo de oportunidad más
bajo en la producción de balones de
básquetbol con esta información podemos
llegar a algunas conclusiones
en primer lugar sabemos que el país debe
especializarse en la producción de
balones de básquetbol porque puede
producirlos a un costo de oportunidad
bajo que el país ve luego sabemos que el
país ve debe especializarse en la
producción de zapatos debido a su costo
de oportunidad más bajo de un balón por
un par de zapatos en comparación con los
1.33 balones por un par de zapatos en el
país
volvamos a nuestra curva de
posibilidades de producción en la que
señalaremos los puntos donde el país
y el país van a producir asumiendo el
principio de la ventaja comparativa el
país
solo va a producir balones de básquetbol
debido a su costo de oportunidad más
bajo esto lo coloca en este punto de su
curva de posibilidades de producción el
país ve solo va a producir zapatos
debido a su costo de oportunidad más
bajo esto pone al país ve en este punto
de su curva de posibilidades de
producción ahora bien se estarán
preguntando cómo el país ve obtiene
balones
si no los produce internamente y como el
país obtiene zapatos si tampoco los
produce internamente por supuesto la
respuesta está en el comercio al
comerciar entre sí ambos países podrán
consumir una combinación de balones de
básquetbol y zapatos que está por encima
de sus curvas de posibilidades
con estas líneas punteadas que estoy
trazando representan lo que podemos
llamar las curvas de posibilidades de
comercio de los países y de observamos
que por medio de la especialización y el
comercio un país puede consumir por
encima de su curva de posibilidades de
producción lo cual no podría conseguir
si solo se dedicará a producir todo por
sí mismo sin comerciar con otros países
los dos puntos que voy a marcar como x
que representan mayores niveles de
consumo de los países que pueden
alcanzar comerciando entre ellos en el
siguiente vídeo analizaremos una
situación distinta en la que no se nos
proporciona el número de productos que
puede producir un país sino la cantidad
de insumos necesarios para producir una
sola unidad de dos bienes diferentes nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo